[Music]  christoph is proud of his 13 kilometers  of hedgerow and as part of an  eu-supported program he is paid to  maintain them  [Music]  hedgerows like these fallow land and  forests are carbon sinks  removing co2 from the atmosphere  they will be vital for the eu to reach  net zero emissions by 2050.  i think it's important to realize that  how we use land has to change in farming  we have more deep-rooted vegetation in  restoration of peatlands and wetlands if  we restore to  biodiverse rich conditions areas that  have been degraded it often is also an  increase of sinks so we can store carbon  while increasing biodiversity  parliament is updating the rules to  change how we use our land to protect  existing hedgerows and forests encourage  rewilding and crop rotation to include  fallow periods  as part of the green deals fit for 55  plan  meps want the eu to move towards a  climate neutral land sector  [Music]